[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the male model runway walk
wolf there's been a lot of you guys have
asked me to make this video Daniel hey
please make if you don't know how to
walk the runway or hey Daniel how do you
walk as a male models so many of you
guys asked me to make the video and it's
finally here
if you're new here to my channel welcome
to deal and model lifestyle subscribe
and click the notification belt so you
won't miss any of the next vs now in
this video I'm gonna take you to two
types of fashion shows first of all I'm
gonna take you to Men's Health Fashion
Show in South Africa these fashion shows
the models are a little bit bigger and
it's more commercial and the other
fashion show is for a Fi
Fashion Week Africa fashion
international now these models are the
typical high-fashion models and they
walk a little bit different as well so
let's get to it I have a dream
[Music]
[Music]
this is just a beginning I'm closing in
there ain't no point a resistance
so first I'm gonna take you to the men's
health Fashion Show hey guys so here we
are the fashion show I'm a little bit
early so they still preparing the wrong
way but I'm just gonna show you how it
looks like this is where they are gonna
sit and view and then this is where we
get them walk the runway is quite long
this is where the cameras are gonna be
and the video camera as well you got the
deejay so they're gonna do the music for
today
[Music]
so we're here this is where AFI Fashion
Week is going to be African fashion
international you ready I'm ready are
you ready let's go
[Music]
[Music]
now just before we really get into it
there's a couple of different ways that
a male model can walk on the runway it
depends on the designer or the brand
who you're working for who's the client
and then also the market or the country
that you're in most countries all that a
bit different they say a couple of
different ways that you can walk on the
runway I'm just gonna mention three of
them now the first one is the kind of
the dead walk I call it the zombie walk
it's where you have no expression at all
you just walk down the runway with no
big movements your arms are down to the
side and you just walk straight forward
and you come back
that's it kind of lifeless that's very
popular in Europe the second one is more
like the gentlemen walk it's the walk
where you show a little bit more
confidence a little bit more personality
but not too much it's very classy
[Music]
and then lastly you have the show where
you walk with a lot of confidence you
show your personality it's more strong
it's more you walk down that runway with
power this is my favorite kind of
fashion show and you get that a lot here
in South Africa all right so how do you
walk the runway as a man tomorrow well
number one the most important don't be
stiff I've seen so many guys that walk
pretty good off the runway you know they
just walk normally naturally and they
look great but once they get on that
stage they focus so much in the hollow
they're walking and they're so stiff you
know it just looks unnatural so loosen
up relax okay
once you do that you do the following
number one is your posture your back
needs to be straight bring your
shoulders a little bit back all right
the reason you do this is because you
show more confidence and the clothes
just look so much better on you as well
number two is take longer steps if you
give nice long strides it just looks a
lot better why because it looks like
you're just kind of flowing across that
runway and you're on a mission if you
give shorter steps it looks like you're
a little bit insecure and it looks like
you have less confidence as well
number three we walk your head has to
look straight ahead not to the sides not
up or down but straight ahead get a
focus point you know so to find the
cameraman or something and just focus on
that and move towards it and that looks
a lot better number four don't let your
arms move all over the place while
you're walking all right just let them
flow naturally with your body with the
same tempo as you walk alright number
five don't walk too slow or too fast
why because it just looks a lot better
also remember you're walking with a
certain song right and that song just
place for a synonym on at a time so your
show has to fit in perfectly with the
timing of the song as well alright now
just a few extra tips for you new models
that's just starting out number one
remember if you have a fashion show
sometimes you have more than one outfit
to change into Roger this is backstage
know every model he gets a certain
amount of outlets not these are mine
usually you get your name here so when
you're done with your first outfit
you've got to run back as fast as you
can change into the other outfit and go
out and stand in your line again
[Music]
busy with the show now you're gonna send
me in the front
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
last one guys just sticking my hair
because I got a hat on
okay
sometimes it's hectic behind the scenes
while the people are watching the show
it looks professional it looks great but
behind the scenes oh my goodness it's
crazy so you got to keep your head and
you've got to be professional you got to
be on time so run and change into your
outfit
[Music]
[Music]
the most outfits I had in one show was
seven for the men's health fashion show
I had four different outfits and also if
you have more than one outfit you need
to remember in what order they need to
be going onto that stage show which
outfit goes first which one goes second
which one got the so hang them on your
hanger in that kind of order so that you
know exactly which outfit to change into
next it will be the worst thing if you
go on that stage and you have the wrong
outfit on also when you go to the
fashion show do not do your own hair
before the time for professional shows
they will always have makeup artist and
hair stylist that would do your hair a
specific way that will fit in with that
show
[Music]
[Music]
max they doing the makeup
another thing that you need to know
because well nobody told me when I first
started modeling is you need to prepare
yourself that fashion shows will take a
lot of time first you got to go to the
castings right and usually there's a lot
of guys there and you need to wait until
it's your turn to go into the casting
sorry I don't have any footage for you
right now because I didn't go to any of
the castings but then when they choose
you for the fashion show but you need to
go to the fitting
now the fitting can take a long time as
well and you need to do a fitting for
every designer that you're gonna walk
for so that takes a long time as you
guys can see there's a lot of brands
over here it's not just one and then you
need to go in another day to do the
actual show so that's three days of your
time for only one show that's a lot of
time and on the day that you have the
show you have to go and you have to do
rehearsals maybe a full dress rehearsal
as well and then the actual show which
is usually at the night time so that's
the whole day there oh my goodness
that's one reason why I really do not
like fashion shows actually that 20
seconds 30 seconds while you're walking
on the runway is awesome yes and it is
fun especially for new models you have
to have that experience and because
there's nothing like that because when
you walk on the runway you feel all the
eyes around you staring at you and at
the front you're almost blinded by all
the camera flashes oh my goodness I
still remember my first ever modeling
job who was a fashion show for SA
Fashion Week oh my
I remember I was so nervous my heart was
just pumping and I had the nerve all
over and when I walked on the runway I
was so nervous my eye started to twitch
a little bit you know and then add on
here my lips started to twitch
anyway I walked I came back and done
when I did the second one done and I
didn't have the twitch anymore I didn't
have those nerves anymore third it
became normal and natural so it would be
the same for you guys we need to it as
well so my best advice to you guys is if
you're a new model just enjoy the
experience all right now if you are
serious about your modeling career check
out my new modelling ebook innovative
description down below I found a lot of
stuff in there a lot of good stuff on
how to start modeling how to do your
portfolio all the questions that you
might have a button modeling is in it so
check it out
if you liked the video give it a thumbs
up subscribe and I'll see you in the
next video cheers guys
[Music]
[Music]